so Cato networks is in a nutshell
revolutionizing how Enterprises build
their Network and network security
infrastructure to take it to a lesser
geeky uh buzzwords and acronyms we're
doing to companies like Palo Alto
checkpoint Cisco Fortinet what Netflix
did to Blockbuster
and that is to take everything that used
to be very physical move it up to the
cloud and take over the business
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by J Ventures a
Community Driven VC Fund in celkon
Valley in partnership with low me Tech
sponsored by Homeward Ventures hippo
Insurance Upper slabs Synergy Global
hello at Stanford leap Birthright Excel
Serena partners and a media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for being here how are you I am
great it's a pleasure to be here
it's a it's great to have you here y'all
and I'm really excited to dive into your
journey and you know why you do what you
do uh you know product marketing
strategic alliances that Cato networks a
big big company a in the security space
with a lot of uh with a lot with a lot
of you know meaningful impact and you
know pushing the boundaries of security
and what we know today and so I'm
looking forward to diving into what
you're doing there as well as your own
personal journey and so it's going to be
a fun conversation and tell me a little
bit about you know how you know if you
think to yourself you know what you
really care about in what you do well
what do you really care about
like the most the thing that most
important to me is the people I work
with I feel that that's what enriches me
and makes me passionate about what I do
and if there's a Cool Tech that comes
along with it that's even better but
it's people first and foremost
and so when it comes to people you know
the people that you work with or do they
you know can do you have some pattern of
what types of relationships do you like
to build or the types of people that you
get energized by when you're around them
well there's like it has to be like a
very large variety of people from
different professions and different
seniorities and I'd like to learn and
and to Mentor when I can and give back
whenever possible
um I try to tell myself that I'm not
hiring people that are similar to me but
I know that's probably not true but I do
try to make my team as versatile as
possible
um prefer people who come with different
background different years of experience
in other domains so we can learn from
each other and have different
perspective of things that's within my
team but overall in the company just you
know working with the people who built
Cato Kramer and go shots and the
entire executive team here this is
mind-blowing it's uh it's a once in a
lifetime opportunity and I'm very
appreciative of of getting it
I love it so so tell me a little bit
about Cato networks and then I'd love to
dive into your specific role in this
rocket ship and and what what your
experience is like
so keto networks is in a nutshell
um revolutionizing how Enterprises build
their Network and network security
infrastructure to take it to a lesser
geeky uh buzzwords and acronyms we're
doing to companies like Palo Alto
checkpoint Cisco Fortinet what Netflix
did to Blockbuster
and that is to take everything that used
to be very physical move it up to the
cloud and take over the business
so so what does that actually mean what
you just described in a limit of terms
yeah right so it means that
traditionally Enterprises they had to
build the network that connects all the
computers and servers and applications
and they used to have autobuy physical
devices which we call appliances that
would build that Network and security it
would be routers and firewalls and
intrusion prevention systems and
optimization devices and they needed to
buy multiple products sometimes from the
seventh or sometimes multiple vendors
and integrate them together and while
they did get the functionality it came
at the cost of a very high complexity
that effectively slowed the business
down and what Cato is doing is that
we're throwing all this complexity away
and we take all those capabilities we've
built them from the ground up as a cloud
service and we're delivering all those
capabilities as a cloud service so think
of everything that used to be complex in
our life that now we just you know go to
Google or to Facebook and everything is
there like we used to have to backup all
the pictures from a digital camera to a
an external drive now I take a picture
in my phone and it's up in my Google
cloud or Apple Cloud and also I don't
need to worry about it it's someone
else's headache we're doing the same for
it managers and network and security
engineers
and and so your role in product
marketing and Alliance is what does that
have to do with a company like keto
networks well what does that even role
mean
so product marketing in general is the
function that translates between the
technical capabilities that the product
or the service has to the values that
the customer is getting or
were experts in storytelling of this is
a certain Technologies this is how it's
going to make your life different and
how this narrative flows from the
technology to the end user and within
Cato this is a very important all jobs
are super important here but my
responsibility and my team's
responsibility is not only to tell the
story of the solution but also to
educate the market that this is the new
path to go we are very disruptive in our
domain we're competing against
traditional huge traditional companies
that existed for 13 20 30 years and now
we're coming and telling customers
everything was done that the way you did
everything until today was okay but
there's a much better way to do it and
this is our way and now we need to
convince the industry to go our way and
this is to a large extent the
responsibility of me and my team
to build the narrative and to tell the
story that convinces customer to buy our
solution
perfect so so let's let's dive into that
a little bit what does that mean for for
your world how do you shift and educate
people's mindsets in something that
sounds really critical and core to their
infrastructure and to the way that they
operate and run their technology
so they
the the blueprint is relatively simple
and then you just need to fine-tune your
approach to it but you have to start
with an agreement with the customer that
they have a problem today something is
not working as good as it should and
once you have that agreement now we can
speak about what can be done better
we can express our own perspective we
sometimes bring objective insights from
objective analyst films such as Gardner
and we say look this is how we used to
do things until today these are the
problems that we hear that everybody is
experiencing from complexity slowness uh
lack of in
not as good as secure as you may want
your network to be
this is what Gardener is saying that
could be the blueprint solution for you
this is well God will say the market is
heading and Cato is perfectly aligned
with that and now let me introduce to
you how Kato solves your problems so
this is how we take the customer from
where they are today to what to where
they can be tomorrow and if we can
convince them that the solution is
viable and that it's proven and that
um that this indeed will solve their
problems then we can progress in the
conversation and do a proof of concept
or a live demo and then continue down
the process of selling the service to
the customers
and so
here in with specifically with kiddo
Network so well what is can you guide me
a little bit through the process of what
it means to to take a customer have
which thinks one thing and you are
coming in your sort of Translating that
thought or evolutionizing that thought
to the next to the next level what does
that engagement look like is it you know
do you is it a very personal sort of uh
guidance is it more technological
guidance how does that work
so it's it's something that is
considered a technological sale which
means that the salesperson representing
Cato needs to understand the
technological domain in which we are
selling and the buyer on the other side
will be head of networking or head of
security or ahead of both it can be VP
or CIO and sometimes
the process is a high touch process so
one of our sales people which we train
internally on how to tell the story
we'll go and meet with someone who
expressed interest in our technology or
in this new Revolution that is happening
in the market and then they would tell
them that story and we're very strict in
how we train ourselves people to tell
the story we try that all of them will
tell it as much as we can exactly the
same
and they'll go through that process
they'll speak with they'll meet with the
prospect either over Zoom or preferably
face to face and then they'll understand
how their Network and network security
looks to date out of that they will be
able to find the points which are
challenging them today and tie those to
the solution that we are offering
so that is the process from taking a
customer from a point that they're just
thinking about something maybe at a very
high level it's a background project or
maybe it's like you know it's a project
on the agenda and
progressing them to a point that they
express High interest in cater to a
degree that they would like to see a
second meeting a product demo they would
like a hands-on experience on the
product and then eventually convincing
them to buy
and and one thing that I that I love you
know in general is sort of the briefing
culture and learning because it sounds
like you know in the in this process
there's a lot of learning to be done as
you fine-tune and but not just for the
specific you know verticals and and how
how this is relevant and and what the
story is uh which is you know the story
itself is it's truth but but then you
you want to know you know you want to
provide it in a way that the different
personas are able to accept it and to to
understand it how do you how do you
learn
you know to evolve in the story you know
do is there something for you as a
leader that you think about or some
methodology that you learn along the way
and you get to to sort of retrain
yourself and the team as you go along
yeah so the the way that we pitch the
product today the way our sales people
pitch the product today is version
20 of the presentation we always
continue to improve it over time it's
driven by multiple reasons but the most
dominant one is that we listen to how
ourselves
deliver the pitch when it's recorded or
so for example and we listen to how the
customers react what questions they ask
whether what we're telling resonates
with them or not whether do we need to
educate them or now they're familiar
enough with the acronyms in in the space
that we are selling in that kind of
effect how we how we shift the
presentation I can tell you for example
that in the early days
we had a page that would take about 30
minutes to explain the problem the
blueprint solution the Cato
implementation of that solution
and that would be a long pitch and if I
could do it in 30 minutes sales people
usually would do it in 35 to 40 and that
lives very little time for the
salespeople to actually now have an open
conversation about what's resonate with
the customer and what's next etc etc
so we did an optimization process where
we compressed the pitch to be 15 minutes
and that gives tons of time to go into
more advanced conversation and not only
that we compressed it at the end of the
page we now present a menu slide which
links to many sub presentations
so if we finish the pitch the customer
says okay I'd like to learn more about
this topic or the other topic they
already have the next slides for it but
now there are more targeted towards what
interests the customer rather than
giving a general pitch this is part of
the optimizations that we do
it requires High touch between me and my
team and the sales organization we meet
with them we speak with them they know
the Israeli culture so the very honest
and direct with us which we I personally
super appreciate if something doesn't
work they'll come and say to my face and
that's that's the only way to improve
that's very good how do you go from a 30
minute pitch to a 15 minute pitch I
assume I assume that you're not speaking
faster I assume that it's more so that
you're condensing the content how do you
how do you decide which content is
relevant for everybody versus which
content should move to the appendix so
that you can potentially double click on
it when it's relevant
so it's a it's a process that
until now I walked with it only together
with the with my CMO and it's a process
where we review our own slides over and
over again any questions I'll say we
question ourselves whether that piece of
information is really necessary do I
need to say each and every single world
can I replace a paragraph or a sentence
with an image and if so how can I
develop that image that just by
presenting it on the screen it would
automatically be understood and I won't
have to spend 15 seconds or 20 seconds
speaking about it then I can just say a
few words and I put together with the
image would send the message
it's a lot of you know internal thinking
a lot of Sleepless hours
um in in Creative time which is super
super challenging but when you get to
the final results you can see the
journey that you made and that's very
fulfilling
that I love that and and a little bit
about the Strategic alliances part of
your role what does that even mean
strategic alliances for for companies
such as yours
so there are some technologies that
um
we have benefits of sharing what we know
how to do with other technological
companies in our space and then we can
create Partnerships
and then my role is to find the right
companies to partner with it needs to be
a condition or a situation when where we
are not competing with each other that
it's it has to be a win-win situation
something that everybody says you know
as a slogan who deals with business
development but not everybody practices
I need to make sure that my partner is
going to come out Happy from this
partnership especially since those
alliances are coming across multiple
years and I need to make sure that we'll
be happy with this partnership and
sometimes you start with one partner you
see during the course of the negotiation
and the legal processes that it's not
really working and the chemistry is not
there and you switch to another one
I start with looking at companies that I
think that their technology complement
ours and we can complement theirs and
there's a good business case and then I
try and find the right people to speak
with in the company
and
their relations that can be built in the
way each
peer of Mind represents their company
and how I represent mine and whether
we're going through a sleazy negotiation
or an honest negotiation even when there
are commercial aspects
really impacts my judgment if this is
the right partner
to work with or not
and I've been in situations where I
spent long months working on a
partnership that kind of exploded last
minute and I think that always it's good
to have it happen before a contract is
signed rather than after
so there's like on the one side there is
the logical part of my brain that looks
at like this is the potential this is
the busiest potential this is the
business partner the potential
partnership this is what I can achieve
from it or what Cato can achieve from it
and there is the emotional side of my
brain that says if those are the people
that this company chose to represent
them and if this is how they conduct
business and negotiations and legal
conversations
maybe that should raise a flag to me and
I always try to combine both factors in
my in my judgment
very very cool if you look at it more
holistically obviously you're it sounds
like you're very intentional about what
you do and you're thinking a lot about
you know the way that you you made
judgment calls and the way that you
improve and and uh it sounds like
there's a lot of teamwork being done
here to to try and figure out you know
these right sweet spots well what do you
enjoy most about what you're doing
well where do I stop
um
first of all I love coming to the office
um so I'm we're walking hybrid I come to
the office for sometimes five days a
week even though there are some
significant commute because I love the
interaction with people I love the whole
conversations I love the spontaneous
brainstorming I think that enriches
everybody and especially here at Cato
for me
um I've been with the company for seven
years now which is a very long period
and it's a crazy roller coaster to work
at a company that moves at the pace in
which Kato moves and not even once have
I felt in any shape or form of
conversation that someone is acting as
if they are the smartest person in the
room
and I think that for me generates the
optimal working atmosphere I feel that I
can learn from so many people and have
what to contribute people are open to
listen to my opinion and to my thoughts
even if those are silly thoughts that
happens very often
um
it keeps me very passionate about the
working environment and the technology
that scada is building and the service
is so mind-blowing this is like Cutting
Edge everything is new almost never done
before moving at scale extremely fast
beyond what I can comprehend sometimes
um it's like you know in being working
at a startup is something that
actually had several conversations about
there is kind of the notion that you can
progress your career by jumping between
companies every two or three years get a
higher position and evolves through that
and maybe it's true that was not my
career path but working in the same
company for a very long time speaking
seven years here I walked to the
previous company for 10 years at the
startup until it got acquired you see
how this thing starts from an idea and
it gets up to a full-blown company that
actually sells and those value those
customer feedback and those the change
and you innovated something and you made
a difference you can only get that
perspective if you're there for the
entire Journey and for me looking at the
pace in which Cato is growing
um we've made it from one million dollar
in annual sales to 100 million in five
years wow which is blazing fast
and I'm proud of that I'm humbled and
I'm honored to be part of that and be
part of an amazing team that achieved
that and we know where we want to go to
the in the future I would miss all of
that if I would switch company every two
or three years I wouldn't be sitting
here so excited about it
that's amazing that that's really really
cool in there and I think more than
anything over this conversation it's
very you know the way that you speak
about all the different things you're
doing and the way that your the
evolution you pretty much articulated
over you know over these 20 minutes sort
of the journey that you've been on and
uh and so now that you're you're sort of
framing it as to the the impact of
what's happened at Cato over these years
it translates very nicely into how you
were talking about the optimizations
that you're making and the storytelling
and the in the finest of it and so I
really appreciate this conversation it
goes by way too quickly and I really
appreciate it and your time and your
energy and thank you for the inspiration
over these 20 minutes and best of luck
with Cato and with everything else that
you'll do thank you
thank you very much Michael it's been a
pleasure
thank you